suddenly I don't know how great of an
idea this is but we're going with it no
hi my name is Grace help me no no you
know your life is different now I wanted
to do a follow along makeup tutorial
video in which I follow along someone's
makeup tutorial that they've already pre
posted this is not a new or novel idea I
just wanted to do it I know cuz Wow well
you really feel about this idea on that
note my own dog presenting her [ __ ]
to me I decided to follow an actual
child's makeup tutorial I myself am very
much a child my house is filled with
juvenile things so I felt like this is
more my speed than following some very
difficult bag makeup tutorial or like
going out makeup tutorial I feel like
this is something I might actually be
able to do so I looked up child's makeup
tutorial and this was the first thing
that came up cutest kids makeup tutorial
I'm going to attempt to follow this
little girls makeup tutorial to the best
of my ability
please note I'm not making fun of this
child intentionally is the video from
the Leroy's who I don't know anything
about I can assume that they're like a
family vlogging channel and they even
write in the description Harry
her name's Perry she's already cool sack
wanted to film another kids makeup
tutorial before everyone gets all worked
up she is 5 she's five oh five oh five
year-olds makeup tutorial she doesn't
wear makeup every day she's beautiful
the way she is this is just for fun this
video is also just for fun here we go
we're gonna follow five year-olds makeup
tutorial and I thought my creative brain
was all dried up okay
nervous I'm like already getting nervous
through the neck of Victoria I girl
that's all I do
her setup is already so much better than
mine Harry how you do that yes oh this
is gonna be real okay I haven't watched
this yet at all just brought over like a
bag of stuff with me and hopefully I
have this stuff similar to what she's
using so we're gonna start
oh you're a mess rub it in it's going
quick oh I actually poked myself in the
eye I'm an idiot
Perry I've had to do the giggle okay
hold on
so do I look pretty what are you using
on your cheeks translucent powder oh I
don't have that oh this is very telling
wait the brush make it fun
oh me too Barry
next what what's that what okay I
haven't made it fun for me yet I'm gonna
make it fun for me we are yeah I don't
have a palette with me hold on I need a
palette okay
we're gonna use this what are you doing
where'd you get that brush you got a
brush Oh where'd you get that brush damn
it what color we got here
pink okay I'll use a pink
good whoa what are you doing you're
doing dark in the creases like that okay
can you see it yeah I think it's kind of
showing oh wow oh wait you do look
pretty and I do like your bun hold on
there we go now I like your bun Dremel
oh she plays music - yeah you're using
mascara you can do anything it's a
little bit more okay your beautiful
island lipstick oh do I have that I
don't have so much in here sorry don't
curse I have this okay do you think I
look pretty comment down below
press the sky button make sure to give
it a big thumbs up we
[Music]
Oh virtual-reality what's going on we'll
see you another time
bye I think I nailed it I don't curse
look at this wait time is five years old
I know that Wow I do feel pretty come on
down below if you think I look pretty
Thank You Perry for that and to the
Leroy's we're hopefully not taking any
offense to me just trying to look as
adorable as their child is I think I've
truly found art that is my speed Wow
well thank you guys so much for watching
leave a comment down below on how pretty
I look don't forget to hit sky button
because I make videos other than that I
don't know and also thank you to Lola
for sponsoring this YouTube video if you
don't know Lola get ready Lola is a
female found a company that makes
organic cotton tampons pads liners
all-natural cleansing wipes and they're
great if you didn't know the FDA doesn't
require brands to disclose a
comprehensive list of things that are in
their feminine care products so most
brands do not but Lola is completely
transparent Ola tampons pads liners are
made from 100% organic cotton they have
no added chemicals fragrances synthetics
or dyes they also have a subscription
process so you can make your delivery of
their Lola products fully customizable
you can choose a mix of products mix of
absorbency number of boxes and frequency
of delivery they make it's so wonderful
for the thing every month that is so not
wonderful
Lola actually started sponsoring my
podcast months and months ago and they
sent me a box of their tampons and I
freaking love them look I even have an
old one floating around in my bag from
probably a month ago the box that they
deliver them in is sleek and discreet
which I love obviously being discreet
now you can get 40% off your first month
subscription by going to my Lola comm
and using promo code great how they when
you subscribe if I had a nickel for
every time I had to make a
temporary toilet paper tampon because
the Red River float unexpectedly and I
had someone over that I didn't want to
explain this to I would have enough
money to buy stuff at a 99-cent store
probably thank you for sponsoring this
video Lola how appropriate that product
for periods while I'm following a five
year olds makeup tutorial lots of layers
in this video